gilbert part en voyage quelques jours il
doit placer max en pension le gardien de
la pension demande à gilbert de signer
une décharge de responsabilité
ce qui ne devait pas arriver arriva max
s'est blessé à son retour
gilbert est furieux il se rend chez le
vétérinaire ça va lui coûter quelques
centaines de dollars
gilbert s'informe il est étonné
d'apprendre que même s'il a signé une
décharge il a des recours
pourquoi parce que dans un contrat entre
commerçants et aux consommateurs
la loi interdit au commerçant de limiter
ou d'exclure ses responsabilités la
pension pour animaux ne peut donc pas
nier sa responsabilité la décharge est
nul
la pension at elle fait preuve de
négligence ce soir la cour de le dire
mais une chose est sûre gilbert a des
droits
attention de les faire valoir leurs
héros de l'histoire chien qui aboie ne
mord pas fort d'une décharge peu
impressionnés mais n'a aucune validité